president biden's border crisis turning
deadly the white house finally reacting
to the tragic death of a texas national
guard member who had been missing since
friday officials recovering the body of
a 22-year-old bishop evans he heroically
jumped into the rio grande river to try
and save two illegal immigrants before
disappearing under the water they
survived but evans was swept away
officials believe the migrants evans
saved are drug smugglers
the white house weighing in today and
saying well don't blame the white house
of course our heart goes out to his
family and to his loved ones does the
white house feel any responsibility for
his death given that
there's reporting that he lost his life
allegedly trying to save
two migrants who were smuggling drugs of
course we are mourning the the loss of
his life and we are grateful for the
work of every national guardsman i would
note that the national guard work for
the states and so he is an employee of
the texas texas national guard and his
efforts and his operation were directed
by there not by the federal government
wow
yeah so dramatic new video from texas
shows how the tragedy was possible
migrants seen avoiding mexican officials
and running into the rio grande river
border patrol then forced to go out and
rescue them and all of this comes as
biden faces bipartisan heat to keep
title 42 in place some democrats now
claiming the president is out of touch
with what is happening
we need to listen to the border
communities this message of lifting
title 42 is going to go straight to the
criminal organizations what we're seeing
is large numbers coming in the messages
that are going out to the smugglers and
to into the migrants is that on may 23rd
you can go ahead and come in
jesse waters give us your thoughts today
well biden has blood on his hands and
now both hands because remember brian
terry
he was the border patrol agent that got
shot after that botched gun running
operation where they let all these black
market firearms go to the cartels
he was the vp and it was his justice
department that ran that stupid
operation so this is another dead
american that the president really needs
to acknowledge more than blaming
somebody else
the illegal immigration is now rising
faster than inflation and that is a huge
problem cartels are making 25 billion
dollars in profits how come we don't
hear anything from liz warren or bernie
sanders about breaking up the big
cartels it's always about breaking up
big tech and big oil let's break up the
big cartels we can do that because i
think the cartel wages are rising faster
than inflation they don't pay any taxes
there biden doesn't even know what
title 42 is
he confused it with the mask mandate on
the planes so this guy's out to lunch
and if you think things are bad wait
till the end of the month it is going to
be so
ugly when you see these visuals because
that's what changes the country's
perspective the visuals of them pouring
across and like that and having no plan
and no system and we're not saying we
don't want illegal immigrants geraldo we
just want to process and some of them
are deadly one of them just murdered
someone here in new york over the
weekend but that right there
if you see that right there over and
over and over again for the next month
this country is going to revolt against
the administration
greg let's get your thoughts on it and
then i'll play a little something for
you from jen saki um well
the infuriating thing about this is that
there's there's a
it's victim preference the the the
democrats the media really only get
upset when the victims suit their
politics right
why isn't it we're talking about this
but
it goes against the typical media
narrative you know a member of law
enforcement gave his life to save
illegal aliens that's not their
narrative because generally you have to
be anti-cop so they're gonna actually
bap at this they're gonna put it they're
gonna they're gonna hide it the obvious
comparison is the border cop that was
accused of whipping haitians that was a
three-day cycle of outrage everybody was
flipping out it was based on pure
slander right now you have a dead
national guardsman how long do you think
that story will last because the only
law enforcement story they like is the
one in which they are the oppressor not
the oppressed and in this case this guy
was a hero trying to save criminals and
that's an amazing story that the
democrats hate because let's not forget
they were behind defunding the police
they they were behind all the negative
stuff that was said about the cops
imagine
if he had not done this if he had let
the narco traffickers die and that was
on film
you that would be on a loop on cnn and
msnbc for days look at these guys there
you know and it also ticks me off about
saki sake they were doing
she said oh it's the tech it's it's the
state well the state is doing that job
because because because our government
has abdicated their responsibility if
they had actually done something that
guy would be alive right now right and
that if the direction is to save people
again to like who do you choose yes to
save he didn't he didn't ask he didn't
think about it is this a drug dealer he
just did his job and his responsibility
gensake made some comments about the
previous president and the border wall
do we have that
the former president invested billions
of dollars in a border wall that was
never going to work or be effective
instead of working towards comprehensive
immigration reform as part of the
president's proposal he put forward on
his first day in office he proposed
investing in smarter security at the
border something he'd be happy to work
uh with governors on and and certainly
we're open to having that conversation
whenever they're ready to do that
okay so their own department of homeland
security says that they are anticipating
18 000 migrants trying to pass per day
right uh if title 42 is lifted she's
talking about smarter security at the
border we tried that with obama we spent
billions of dollars for this smarter
security at the border she's wrong the
wall works it stops people from coming
across but i think the most incredible
part of all of this is that there is a
plan i every day i ask the same question
what is biden's end goal here how long
can he keep our borders open what he's
done now is he's given the the mexican
cartels and everyone else a six-week
advance notice so the surge is starting
now and they're right now they're not
even using title 42. so now we lose
someone who's trying to save people
coming here illegally so that they can
join in the cornucopia of goods whether
it's healthcare education medication
welfare you name it they get everything
they even get lawyers where people who
come here legally have to pay for their
own lawyers and this guy not only is
looking to save them he ends up
allegedly saving two people who are
involved in narcotics trafficking and
you know what that we would lose a law
enforcement life
to someone who was part of a
transnational drug cartel that starts in
china in an undeclared war against
americans by sending fentanyl in through
the mexican cartels is the ultimate in
the government not losing uh not
protecting us why did this man die
why are border patrol babies sitting why
are the border patrol basically being
told to facilitate in this surge of
illegals at the border i'm tired of
talking about migrants they are illegal
and i'll tell you why
now all of a sudden all the democrats
are saying we are we are against this uh
this surge we gotta stop but well
they're not stupid they know the
elections are coming and so what they're
trying to do now is they're trying to
make it look as bad as it can
so that they can force the republicans
and everyone else to do
immigration reform the system is not
broken
biden has broken the system by allowing
everyone to come into this country and
shame on him and what he's doing to a
sovereign nation geraldo i think that
the lack of compassion for these people
who are risking everything i've lost
their risk to see the desperation of
them running into the river but that's
i'm not going to talk about compassion
or anything mushy like that tonight i'm
going to
suggest
something and it's going to circle back
to specialist bishop evans
title 42
is a fraud
title 42 is a health ordinance an
executive order to prevent the spread of
covet that's what title 42 is
the government says
the pandemic is over or ending
there is no just cause for keeping title
42 why not do this we all want
what title 42 does to mitigate the surge
of migrants don't we we all want it why
not codify title 42 make title 42 a law
make up the specialist bishop evans law
that does everything that title 42 does
and force congress to vote on it in
public let every republican will vote
for it many many democrats that's the
real drama many democrats will also vote
for the bishop evans act i say make
title 42 the specialist bishop evans act
make it the law of the land where no one
hides and if biden wants to veto it then
let congress override his veto he won't
put it to the floor
nancy and chuck won't put it on then the
democrats will be routed in november in
a way that they
they they are working deserved thank you
profoundly now if they do that if they
if there's a law if someone has the guts
to codify a law make them a bill make
them vote make every one of them vote
and if she doesn't let it mexico
i need to work on my volume all right
coming up liberals freaking out after
elon musk finally takes control of
twitter the breaking details next hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else